good day be home by dinner I love you
good morning Catherine
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
Catherine Angela if you can hear this
hey you found her
doing on day in those woods you're just
walking and walking
Angela can you tell your dad how long
you were gone it's a few hours
baby you've been gone three days
laughs
[Music]
what'd you say I didn't say nothing
so I heard you say something
hey baby
okay
wherever those girls when they brought
something back with them the body and
the blood of Jesus Christ
foreign
body in the blood
the body in the blood the body and the
blood count through the body
ever seen anything like this
on me no but there are people out there
who have
[Music]
you have some experience with possession
yes more than that life
I believe you can help get our girls
back
exorcism is a ritual every culture every
religion they all use different methods
it's going to take all of them
[Music]
we've met before
mother
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do
is that Catherine's heartbeat they're
beating in shape
[Music]
we have a very important mission for
tonight we must use stealth and cut him
to infiltrate the human world and
retrieve
go-kart
okay Batman what I'm just trying to Hype
you guys up let's go from Seth Rogen
comes a movie that crushes for
absolutely every age
amazing insane all right tell me more
it's effortlessly cool and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this year
[Music]
that seemed very dangerous see danger
for breakfast actually I eat pizza with
bits of waffles on it
with the funniest cast ever assembled
enough oh man you can't stop us
we're the only ones who can do this
[Music]
I'm awesome we're brothers We Fight
Together
we're just getting started
[Music]
yeah she sounded like a leader I do oh I
do oh I sound like such a leader and you
ruined it
Ninja Turtles
remember don't let any human see you
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters August 2nd
get your tickets now
hi there uh big dogs I'm trying to get
home I know which way that is oh great
right up my ass oh no that can't be
right this is Will Ferrell I'm lost
you're a stray man you can do anything
you want this beer doesn't taste good
but I like how it's making me feel this
is Jamie Foxx how recently picked this
couch
I can't see dirty too no well I I can
tell looks like she hasn't been washed
in years I'll see you later baby it was
nice to meet you I really should find my
way back home any places landmarks you
remember I remember the devil in the sky
look at that guy and Hell mother son of
a dumb smiles
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse
that is the craziest thing I have ever
seen and I'm Dennis Quaid and Dennis
Quaid has seen some
starving how many of these should we eat
all of them give me a sec whoa you look
different you look different too how so
is it my human hands hold up the cops
what do we do calm down I got this hello
officer none of us shut the up
Strays in theaters August 18 rated R
[Music]
hi my name is Susie Wallace I want to
solve the unsolvable I want to bring
resolution to the most haunting
Mysteries why are you smiling just my
natural expression what is it selfie
[Music]
when I solve this case and become a big
hero I can't wait
it doesn't matter if you have five
suspects or 500 more often than you
think the culprit is right under your
nose
I'm Susie
Susie Ohio's own Nancy Drew
take us through your investigation
I remember learning about heroes in
school but I never thought I'd be
sitting next to one
got chills
I just got chilled
chill everybody else in the world
you Susie never change okay
it was wrong about you even though you
saved the day you still have no social
life
I promise I'm not going to tell anybody
what I found I have no idea what you're
talking about Jesse was wearing this
half a day disappeared you can tell me
what happened
[Applause]
life takes unexpected twists
you're following me they found more DNA
evidence really
it could be the best criminal in the
world but you cannot outrun science
a new tragedy has struck even the most
perfect plans don't always work out
you're my Prime Suspect and my guys
following you for weeks
but eventually a solution will present
itself
you ever had something so crazy happen
to you
you can barely believe that it happened
we have developed a neurotechnology that
allows you
your best self you're still you
the best you
who
and why
it's the ring
it takes you back in time 57 seconds
that's unreal
lucky number seven
15.
15 black yes thank you very much
drop a bang I went to the casino I got
super lucky I had like a bit of an edge
Franklin who is this that's my my twin
sister Natalie
actually oh do you have a pain pillow
they gave her
that will kill my sister I detect the
desire for justice Sig Sorensen is
responsible for the death of thousands
with the drug he knew was devastatingly
lethal but how do I make sure that never
happens to anyone again are you asking
the wrong questions the real
breakthrough it's time travel ignore the
naysayers Franklin because money can buy
you happiness
this is not about your sister this is
about power
don't let the intellectual appear in
here keep you from pursuing what's
burning in here I wish I'd done some
things differently
that thing did you use it with me
I'm going back and redoing things till
you get it right
that what a better future looks like
there's not enough time
[Music]
four three two one today the Egyptian
and Syrian armies launched an offensive
against Israel our enemies hope to
surprise the citizens of Israel on Yom
Kippur our troops are doubt number seven
to one if the Arabs reach Tel Aviv
Israel will be wiped off the map
[Music]
in my day they stood for the prime
minister
is on the line remember that I am first
an American second I am Secretary of
State and third I am a Jew you forget
that in Israel we read from right to
left
the American people will pay a high
price for supporting Israel if we have
to we will fight alone our troops in the
canal they're surrounded you rescue
these boys my little catastrophe
is the Americans throw us to the dogs I
will not be taken alive Egyptians
acquire the cruise missiles
[Music]
well I'm not going to get under the
table but don't let me stop you
[Music]
the Russians are preparing 11 Airborne
divisions when I was a child in Ukraine
they would beat Jews to death in the
street for fun I am not that little girl
hiding in the cellar
[Music]
do you know how many people died all
those boys I will carry that pain into
my grave
[Music]
we will keep fighting for a guarantee of
life
and peace
[Music]
is
so perfect
[Music]
country
lose them perfection
oh
right
foreign
[Music]
goodbye
I just don't know what she's told you
about me she said you were a degenerate
and you left because you hate us she
forced me out of your life
you think I'm too stupid don't
understand I'm not saying that
do you know what being trans is
[Music]
did you know that John is back in the
city yeah
I haven't seen you in a while do I look
different to you no
still you Jessica another you
you remember me Zoe
of course I do you're my sister's
boyfriend was
love just X's are X's for a reason I'm
worried about you don't get caught up in
these momentary feelings
shouldn't have run away if I can take
care of myself yeah then why'd you come
to me
if you're waiting to see if this is a
phase it's not do people say I look
happier you're more comfortable the way
it moves
not as tense
when she gets aggressive she's not
talking to you she's talking to all the
sadness that's inside of her
I want you to know that I've interest
disappear for no reason
wonder if it's always
look at me
be proud
you can't tell Mom about any of this
obviously
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on you